hey you guys it's time for our Christmas
edition of the movie retrospective yeah
we got a couple of good ones now what I
was initially going to do I mean I'm
gonna do one of the ones I was initially
gonna do which is Christmas evil aka you
better watch out because it was on
shudder my original plan was to do that
along with Silent Night deadly night
however by the time I went to watch the
movies for the review shudder had taken
down Silent Night deadly night so I said
okay well I guess I can't do that one
but what ended up happening was that we
were on Netflix and we saw much to our
delight yeah that they great
2018 Christmas movie starring Kurt
Russell Kurt Russell as Santa Claus is
bad as Santa Claus like the real Santa
Claus and I was like okay we have to do
that one like even if it even if it's
not good like but as it turned out I
love them it actually was fantastic it
was like really good I really recommend
it so those are the two that we're gonna
do for our little Christmas movie
retrospective special so let's kind of
talk a little bit about the first one
which is called Christmas evil now this
came out in 1980 very famously it's John
Waters favorite Christmas movie he calls
it the best Christmas movie of all time
um I would probably argue with that
assertion but it is actually a really
weird interesting Christmas movie it's
usually classed as a Christmas slasher
but I would not call it a slasher I mean
the guy does kill people in it like
dressed up as Santa Claus and I should
note that this movie actually predated
Silent Night deadly night you know where
there was the big controversy about
Santa going around axing people this
actually came out first and he did
actually kill some people with a hatchet
but I kind of feel like this movie is
more in the line of something like it's
like a psychological thriller type of
thing with some slasher elements it's
almost like a character study type of
thing I would put it like it's kind of
similar to maniac which we mentioned
before maybe the driller killer it's
almost kind of like a low-rent Christmas
version of taxi
that's not too weird to say it's kind of
like that because a lot of it focuses on
the main character whose name is Harry
and he was this I guess like back when
he was a kid in 1947 like he saw his dad
dressed up as Santa but he thought it
was really Santa but Santa was looked
like given oral to his mom like it's
kind of what I thought the implication
was there yeah and he was like
traumatized by that because he thought
it was really Santa's Rus like no it was
dad and he had like this big you know
traumatic episode from it and when he
got older like and got into middle age
you see like the inside of his sad ass
apartment and he's like this Santa
obsessed dude he's like Scott Santa
pajamas he's got like Santa [ __ ] like
all over his house and he also creepily
enough he watches all the neighborhood
kids like through binoculars and he has
these big Ledger's like in his house
with like good kids and naughty kids and
he has all their names in there and he
like spies on him and then he like
writes down what they do and [ __ ] but
like as the movie goes on like he gets
nutty earned it and eventually he starts
thinking that he actually is Santa Claus
and that it's his job to kind of go mete
out justice to the good and the naughty
people like children and adults it's
kind of a strange like I said it's a
very strange movie because you almost
kind of feel sorry for the dude like
he's such a slob he's so crazy and like
some of the people in the movie are like
such dicks to him that you can almost
kind of understand like why he would
sort of go off and it's just like you
know I'm just gonna stick a [ __ ]
sword through your eye cuz [ __ ] you
buddy you know what I mean and it's like
he's almost like he gets to a point
where his dementia is like he feels like
he needs to like embody the Christmas
spirit and if people are gonna be like
taking the piss or they're being mean to
him on Santa on Christmas or they're
gonna be mean to other people then he's
gonna do something about that like
Krampus style you know what I mean so
he's gonna like kill him and stuff but
like I said and I'm not gonna spoil the
ending scene because it really
made me laugh out loud because like I
was not expecting it whatsoever because
like I said this is a very gritty you
know sort of 1980 like kind of dirty
rowdy kind of you know movie about a sad
dude that thinks he's really Santa Claus
I'm like how that kind of plays out he
does good [ __ ] to it's not all like him
killing people like I said so it's not
like Silent Night deadly night where
it's like a slasher but um it's just
kind of like I don't know it's it's a
very strange movie it's kind of
languidly paced I can see what John
Waters liked about it the cinematography
is actually very nice they have it on
shutter and like I said it's called
Christmas evil but the title card when
it comes on actually says you better
watch out and I think that's mainly what
it's known as it's also known as terror
in Toyland which I don't know why but I
mean the the main guy works at a toy
factory so I guess that's why but that
seems like a stupid title but you know I
recommend it if you want like a kind of
a strange dark Christmas movie like I
said in the vein of maniac or taxi
driver or something like that where it's
kind of like mostly like a long
psychological study of somebody losing
their marbles and then occasionally
there's like some people getting chopped
up with hatchets and stuff like that but
you know so check it out it's on shudder
it's kind of a weird movie and I think
it kind of gets I mean there's a lot of
killer Santa movies out there and I
think silent I deadly night is a lot
better known but this actually took
place a little bit before that I can see
how some people might like these slasher
Santa movies you know I mean like yeah
they're an alarming omission if you want
to see you want to not want to see a
slasher movie just has to be Christmas
so you can put that on me personally I
kind of prefer to Krampus theme yeah I
do too like I you know the Santa ones
are kind of they're kind of it's also
kind of it's kind of a contrived a feel
very contrived to me yeah I feel out of
our way to put this in the but you know
I'm sure it's possible to write a real
good one just I haven't really seen a
real good one yeah it just looks kind of
contrived but the crapless ones to me
are like spot-on I look you got a good
force which is Santa an evil force which
is Krampus I'm like yeah I'm like super
is that more Krampus movies weren't made
like before because it seems like I mean
the Krampus legend is been around like
in Europe and stuff like that for you
know forever and it looks badass
yeah and it looks badass do you think
that like more people in the United
States would have known about it but it
only seems to have got real popular like
maybe the last 10 20 years they didn't
know about it back in the eighties yeah
yeah I had never heard of crayons back
in it and I was like a goth kid you know
what I mean so you'd think I would know
all about that creepy [ __ ] but I didn't
um if they did they would have made him
right right so it's like that would have
gone right in with this crazy [ __ ] like
raw head wrecks and all the monster
movies of the ain't you know old
European monsters they come back Krampus
was perfect for that but I don't think I
don't think the Hollywood guys that made
these things you know they there didn't
have the awareness yeah well like I said
it wasn't really in the public
consciousness and I think they thought
well even if you did know about it like
if he made it people would be like what
the [ __ ] is a Krampus you know what I
mean like they didn't know but was like
now there we go like he made that up
yeah like that's not real yeah yeah they
were but yeah that um I actually really
liked the one that was just called
Krampus that came out however long ago
was 2012-2013 I can't remember but it
was a you know several years ago I
actually really liked that um I was
thinking like going into that it was
gonna be like a comedy and it did have
like comedic elements but it was like
actually a lot darker than I thought and
I loved at the end I thought the end was
like fantastic um there's also like you
know while we're talking about Christmas
movies might as well talk about some
other good Christmas movies we just
watch cus I I like Christmas themed
horror movies not necessarily Santa
slashers cuz they tend to be kind of
Sammy but I do like horror movies that
are set around Christmas time the one
that's called a Christmas horror story
it's an anthology movie and I had seen
it before but I just watched it again
last night and that is actually really
good I would recommend it and it has a
Santa Krampus fight also has elves
getting a zombie virus and Santa having
to like take him out also has the shat
in playing a radio he's kind of like the
frame story and he's like a radio DJ and
he just gets drunk or a drunker and
drunker more depressed like over the
course of the movie and it's like really
really funny he has like some really
great lines but it's for two
stories like a varying quality but
there's a Krampus one in there there's
one like about a changeling that's very
cool it's like really creepy and then
there's one about like some kids that go
into like a like a school basement where
like a murder took place like the
Christmas before and they're making a
documentary about it and stuff but um it
was a creep show type yeah it was like I
said it was four or five different
stories it was that's actually pretty
good um I saw this really weird one last
year called red Christmas Dee Wallace
was in it I think I saw on Netflix I
don't know if it's still there but it
was like the opening scene I was like
Merry Christmas everybody the opening
scene was like heard of an abortion
clinic he's like get an abortion and
then like somebody bombed it and then
like they tossed like the the fetus like
just into a bucket in the corner and
it's little hand comes out - you're like
oh man so like the aborted fetus once
he's grown up he like oh yeah yeah I saw
that one that was so good that was
awesome it was so good that it was like
weird and ridiculous and their baby
tries to come back I'm I'm your son yeah
it's like it's like the weirdest premise
but I really liked it I was in like the
family dynamic like she gets all her
family like back to her house cuz she's
gonna sell the house and blah blah blah
and they all like hate each other and
they're all like sniping that movie was
damn absurd it was but I really like
this you got to see somebody get killed
by a blender which is oh yeah just like
you know is most disturbing
most disturbing you pausing at the most
disturbing movie possible they were like
going out of their way yeah push your
buttons let's just offend everybody
everybody that's pretty good I want to
see that again actually but I like you
know I like that kind of [ __ ] we'll see
that what again this so let's talk about
cuz I can't think of any other ones that
I've seen recently but let's talk about
the wonderful wonderful I was at dude I
was just ok I'm scrolling through
Netflix I guess they do a Christmas
movie or several Christmas movies every
year but they're one this year they were
very excited about it because it's like
I probably the only thing that they had
to say they have a script they probably
have nothing they just said Kurt Russell
as Santa Claus yeah and everybody's like
yes make that movie here's all the money
you know I'm a fan of crust I love
crustle that's why the night is in
this stands the test of time to cross
the stands at esta crustle I think yeah
it's going to do really good it really
good movie I kind of want to buy it
because I kind of want this to be like a
yearly watch that every year right like
just like on Thanksgiving I always yes
mr. Kurt Russell plays Santa Claus and
he's actually doing the things that
Santa Claus does and that's what gives
it possibility he's got supernatural
powers he's got a sleigh it looks like
it looks almost like a jet in the inside
of it yeah it's got you know IKEA
looking yes weakens and lives on the
nerve boys got he's got elves he speaks
elvish to him yeah it's bizarre but
actually it's magic it's not technology
but it does kind of look technological
and it just does bunch of cool [ __ ] but
that's good yeah and you know runs into
trouble he's got little meters to say
you know what what what is what the
Christmas Christmas spirit level is and
if it goes to yeah he's got he's keeps a
crime level down and he's got to deliver
all these packages is on time and these
kids sneak into his sleigh and screw him
up he crashes it does a bunch of stuff
to get all of his slayed and all this
reindeer back together and got to get
the elves to help get him out of jail he
goes to prison yeah you know when Santa
Claus goes to prison for a while you
know I mean honestly what it is the
producer of it's very famously is Chris
Columbus who always heated home alone he
did Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone yeah so and the director of it was
this is actually the director of it was
his first live-action film I can't
remember his name but it's the same guy
that did the Angry Birds movie quality
is very high the soundtracks good yeah
it's kind of like it feels like a
stabile burg movie
yeah it's Spielberg in it's like a
fantasy there's like a lot of really
cool like magic and special feels like
Harry Potter kind of [ __ ] in it yeah but
also it's it feels like a throwback to
like your darker 80s kids movies like
gremlins like gremlins The Goonies or
adventures in babysitting or something
like that where it's little kids and
it's like you know kids can watch it
ah but adults could watch it - I
wouldn't put ya kiddush I mean it was it
says fun for the whole family that's a B
it's a family movie I'd almost put it up
there with like et yeah like et et or
maybe like Close Encounters of the Third
Kind something like that yeah there is
there's danger in it yeah yeah yeah you
know it's [ __ ] like that house like bad
[ __ ] happens
got Russell sings in it there there are
hookers yeah yeah yeah he's doing kind
of like Indiana Jones style Santa Claus
action it's just enough I liked a minute
because he seems like um he's mad that
they keep drawing him fat and he's like
who is that I'm not fat I know that's
like that's one of the recurring got a
cool a plan - outfit yeah cuz he looks
really good in this like he looks super
cool with a beard anyway and like I said
that's probably why they were like oh he
should totally play saying angles on it
but he's really good he's like he's kind
of a funk Euler and the fact that he's
like he doesn't really take any [ __ ]
he's not mean like he's a little bit
cranky a little bit but you can see why
because you know these kids like snuck
in it's not a [ __ ] yeah he's nice
though and he's nice and he's like he
gets annoyed and irritating he knows
everything that you had and everything
that you wanted for Christmas yeah you
don't believe in him he starts we'll
remember that time you were 13 they gave
you this doesn't remember that yeah
stuff then there's a bunch of stuff
that's never really been done that I can
sufficiently to my to my satisfaction
what what the North Pole is all about
they show the North Pole the North Pole
base the North Pole a filing card filing
system of where all the data is kept
he's got holographic screens though -
it's pretty cool yeah it's like well oh
you know all the old school letters he
keeps all those gotta bomb looks like a
huge library and it's like I honestly I
love how the little girl that's and the
kids that are really cool - there's like
there's sad family drama it's like these
kids and the family and they're super
into Christmas and their dad as a
firefighter and he died and so you know
in the
you see urns their mom's a nurse and
she's like overworked and she oughta be
home older brother went bad he starts
stealing cars yeah yeah and he starts
like going to a life of crime yeah him
and his sister fighting all the me this
mean to his little sister yeah cool but
yeah so there so there's this whole
thing about like rediscovering family
magic and rediscovering you know that's
the standard like Christmas movie stuff
but you know I really liked the kids in
this they were very charming they
weren't annoying or anything great
soundtrack yes that's the facts really
good I really writing was very good yeah
I really did like I mean it was funny it
was like yeah it had a had a traditional
story structure where there's a
beginning a middle and an end there's no
jumping around or anything it's very
very much like a Spielberg movie very
much gave me that feeling that positive
a feeling that you kind of got from the
Spielberg movies when they were kind of
like kind of like embodying American
middle-class values and like the
American Dream it has you know no
telling that you got when you watched ET
and yet and even Close Encounters was
kind of like that you know it was very
American middle class I always liked
that and I think they've successfully
done that a few times recently we're
talking earlier it's like with stranger
things yeah yeah it's like that which is
a similar vibe we were talking about it
earlier one time in a car is it is it
possible for these new directors to
actually kind of rekindle that feeling
you used to get when you used to see
those old movies that kind of glorify
the American middle-class culture you
know in the value system you know and I
wasn't really sure that they could but
seeing that was like now that's it right
there I think a lot of it the music yeah
that's gonna dialogue and like I said
the producer of this also worked on some
of the you know more iconic movies like
been said another one that really
doesn't real well is like pretty much
all of the back of the future movies
yeah I kind of had this really intense
American feeling to them yeah and like I
said the nice thing about them is that
they were family movies yeah but they
weren't like mawkish they weren't they
weren't sad too sappy they were a sappy
there was like danger like people
actually got killed or or in threatened
you know
to get killed and stuff like that yeah a
good example would be like Indiana Jones
one
yeah that's almost that perfect tone
yeah other ones were okay but one was
really the first one was really the best
one raters a lost art yeah yeah we
talked about that early like week cuz he
bought all the Indiana Jones isn't gonna
box set and it's like when I was growing
up I loved the first Indiana Jones but
the second one Temple of Doom was
actually my favorite but when I saw it
again it's not like I didn't like it as
much really didn't age well yeah I think
it's too it's too screening and zany and
it's Tuesday that character that's you
know Willy or Winnie or whatever really
obnoxious um yeah she just she just got
on my nerves like t2 I didn't like it I
don't think t2 aged world everybody yeah
that kid is so annoying yeah I was like
God that kid there's there's really only
one Terminator movie and it's t1 yeah
that's really the only good one
I have long it's just funny at the time
later we thought I mean I liked Temple
of Doom best when I was a kid because
I'm a [ __ ] it had a good it had
somebody tearing people's hearts out how
can I don't love that it had a good look
yeah but that just the gestalt of of
template of Raiders of Lost Ark is just
about perfect yeah that that movie
Raiders of the Lost Ark and back to the
future the very first one are kind of
neck and neck for about perfect movies
just the tone and there's the edit where
you can just watch them over and over
you know what I mean it's just like and
you get the same feeling every time I
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says I
like frighteners to out that to me I
think a lot of people like fright it's
like you write the long edit yeah you
know because there's a couple different
edits but that blu-ray edit is up there
with Back to the Future for me yeah I
feel like it didn't get a lot of
attention when it first came out because
I don't think they really can get it
great cat Jeffrey Combs yeah I love it
just kind of like get back to the future
with Michael J Fox you know but ghosts
and paranormal stuff and I like he was
kind of like he was kind of like I'm a
dark fallen characters in yeah like a
dark version of anyways yeah but he's
still good guy he was trying to
basically kind of like achieve salvation
really that's yeah salvation story
do it but I think that's kind of what I
liked about this movie the the Santa
Clause crustle movie which is called the
Christmas Chronicles and yes I didn't
mention it it's on Netflix and it just
came out yes you happen again
I better it came out like right around
that yeah on that fixed Christmas
chronicles check it out but yeah I think
that's what I like about this one is
like I'm not gonna say that Kurt also
plays like a darker santa claus cuz like
I said he's he's like the cool dad Santa
Claus yes like he can like crack down if
he needs to and he gets annoyed because
the kids like made his sleigh crash and
life was [ __ ] up his whole plan you
know what I mean so but he's not mean
and he's not mean to them or anything
like that he's actually really charming
like when he tries to go get help and
well you know Santa is like a Lapland is
shaman Oh dad you know which is a
sorcerer yeah basically so that's kind
of how he's portrayed yes that blandish
sorcerer he's got technology and magic
and you know he's not clown you know
he's like something out of out of common
certain ways kind of remind a little bit
of Willy Wonka walk up yeah but you know
Kurt Kurt's got that macho you know
element to him you know sanneh yeah look
he might have a gun on him somewhere you
don't know I would what the Cowboys
seems like that good yeah yeah maybe
like he would keep it a secret
yeah you got to pull out this Warren
arrived he [ __ ] yeah you [ __ ] me Santa
I got resistors deliver [ __ ] to do I got
a schedule to keep
yeah yeah so like I said it's it's fun
for the whole family and like I said a
little it reminded me a lot of movies
from the 80s that were just kind of like
that fun yeah like magical kind of vibe
yes
you know but there was still like a lot
of like adventure deserves a blu-ray
release yeah I don't know why this
didn't have a theatrical release um
it's just one of Netflix and Netflix
yeah but it honestly it's your movie
quality I read that um it actually had
like 20 million streams the first day it
came out which is like that means a huge
yeah that means as a hit yeah so and
it's been getting like pretty decent
reviews
yeah there's a there's a couple key
there's a cameo at the end we're not
it's like the second I heard the voice I
was like oh I know that is so yeah we
really recommend this one also and also
I love the elves yeah elves are like
little they're not they're Hamlet kind
of like the way the gremlins were
handled yeah they were like they're
little bitty they're little bitty
creatures like little bitty creepy
woodland creatures they have like crazy
little boys they do talk they talk but
they don't speak English no no this but
they only speak I don't know if it's
elvish or he thought he said it was a
elvish but it might be lap that's what I
was laughing because that's what was it
because he talked to them and literally
whatever language they some kind of
weird finish and then there was that one
scene too in the restaurant where he was
like trying to get a car right and then
he was like asking all the people he
knew all their names but he could speak
every single language like he gets me a
finish in Chinese and everything like
yeah he's talking to people and like
I'll teach the little elves in the
background make a little hand signs and
make it a little hard because they talk
it's funny and also there was there was
a wonderful scene where one of the elves
like almost like threatened to kill
somebody would chainsaw so that was
pretty cool was that Lars know there was
one in there that was like um there was
one elf that was named Bjorn yeah and he
was like that's all he did was eat candy
canes
he's kind of pudgy and he was just like
Lea ready yeah they don't really look
like people they're more like literally
Al's with clothes on them in a way yeah
yeah they're like little woodland little
Tufts of hair and like they have clothes
on and they talk and have arms and legs
but there's something kind of yeah so
you know get some [ __ ] eggnog or hi
yes it and this that this that this this
is fun for the whole family that's happy
and it is alcohol approved you can
ignore and rum you can you can drink
cool car
you think you want yeah and you can like
yeah you have fun time I want to get it
again get some sugar cookies we're gonna
watch it again we should watch it on
Chris okay
on Christmas Day that'll like Christmas
night Christmas night yeah we should do
that yeah we'll get some booze and some
cookies and yeah we're gonna do the live
stream that [ __ ] wisely get dressed
walking watching it doing comments on
the channel taking super chance do a
super chance yeah that's actually a good
idea which probably be our Christmas
special yeah I don't know if you can do
it that way but yeah because you might I
don't know yeah you probably couldn't
have you can't have it play em right in
the shot somehow yeah because otherwise
you're gonna get in trouble with
copyright violations yeah cuz Netflix is
gonna sue our butts and we don't have
enough money to defend ourselves against
something like that No so anyway hope
you guys enjoyed our little Christmas
special check out both these movies
Christmas evil and the Christmas
Chronicles for your holiday in the
Christmas Brussels Christmas cross all
this and remember if you like the show
to like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially supports show you can go to
our patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar that goes right to a PayPal
account if you would rather make a
one-time donation you may do that as
well and it is much appreciated and
remember our regular shows come out
every Tuesday and we're gonna have a
Christmas special coming up this Tuesday
so be sure to check that out and also we
do 13 o'clock matinee which is new
movies in the theater that comes out
every Sunday so be sure to check those
out too and that'll do it for this
double feature Christmas movie episode
we will see you next time bye